now to an off-duty dr oz
using his medical training to save a
life he told me the situation was
chillingly close to death what exactly
happened
at newark airport on monday the man had
essentially
collapsed face planting there was blood
under his head i
rushed over and there was no pulse
he looked like he was an eggplant a dark
blue and there was no oxygen moving he
was
dying in front of me so i tore shirts
started doing chest compressions
by then we had another officer who had
brought the defibrillator
we shocked him his heart came back and
that man i just texted with his wife
he's in the icu but doing well
okay and i'm very optimistic this is not
the first time we at et we spoke to you
after you
saved a woman outside of radio city
music hall so you have
seconds to begin to apply pressure this
cabin amputated the woman's leg a young
tourist actually 18 years old who's a
dancer
i still stay in touch with her wow a lot
of people don't know this but dr oz not
only saved that woman's life he also
helped her get
a prosthetic leg
you